all righty we're going to get back to
some good sunshine today after all those
high clouds yesterday
temperatures have been very mild this
morning we've been in the 60s around the
valley
not much in the way of wind we've had a
few breezes nellis a few east northeast
breezes this morning
tomorrow is when the big wind comes so
today sunshine
will be keeping it extra warm with those
upper 80s again today just like the
weekend
strong gusty south winds arrive tuesday
into tuesday night
fire watches have been already issued
for our area tomorrow highs will drop
back into the more normal 70s for just a
couple of days
and then we'll get some warmth back
again by the weekend it's all because of
a low pressure system
that will set up over the great basin
and those fire weather watches have been
in all these areas of orange
are under those fire weather watches
clark county for tuesday
over into northwest arizona continues
into wednesday so
i have to be really really careful with
anything that could get a fire started
87 degrees today the clouds will return
tonight
and then they'll move out again later
tomorrow very windy for tuesday still
breezy on wednesday
look at those nice upper 70's that's
where we should be for mid-april
then we'll warm right back up to the
mid-80s later into the weekend